du bout de cette immense table face à
vladimir poutine antonio gutiérrez
plaide pour un cessez le feu et propose
l'aide des nations unies pour évacuer
les civils coincés en ukraine notamment
se réfugier dans l'usinage of talent à
marioupol nous devons travailler avec
les forces militaires russes
ukrainiennes
pour résoudre en priorité le problème de
l'évacuation des civils qui se trouvent
dans l'usiné aux logiques
une aide à laquelle le président russe a
donné son accord de principe selon l'onu
même si lors de l'entretien il continue
d'accuser les ukrainiens de retenir
volontairement des civils pour s'en
servir comme de boucliers
l'usinage opstal est totalement isolé et
j'ai ordonné de ne pas mener l'assaut
donc il n'y a pas de combats autour de
lusine
les autorités ukrainiennes disent qu'il
y à des civils à l'intérieur
si c'est le cas les militaires craignent
un qui sont là doivent les libérer sinon
ils agissent comme des terroristes le
président russe fait référence aux
centaines de civils réfugiés dans cet
immense complexe métallurgique
depuis plusieurs jours le bataillon
azoff avec lequel ils sont retranchés
diffuse régulièrement des vidéos comme
celle ci où l'on voit une femme blessée
parce que les combattants affirment être
une frappe russe lusine est le dernier
bastion de combattants de marioupol dans
cette ville symbole de la résistance
ukrainienne seuls quelques buse
d'évacuation ont pu partir dans cette
ville presque entièrement contrôlé par
les russes quelque cent mille civils
seraient toujours bloquées selon kiev